- Do you know how much
you earn in consulting?
This video is really a juicy one,
because in this video I'm
going to tell you exactly
how much you will earn in consulting
if you work for an MBB
Firm, if you work for Big 4,
a Tier 2 management consulting firm,
including regional differences,
in the US, in Germany, in India,
and many other countries as well.
In addition, I have some precise numbers
on how the working hours differ
among McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
and also all the four Big 4 Firms.
So if you're interested in this,
this video is right for you.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
I'm Heinrich, I'm a former
McKinsey Consultant.
And on my channel, I talk
about how to become successful
in the first years of your career.
So, let's address the
elephant in the room first,
where do I have all this data from?
Because surely this is not data
that is easily made
available to the public.
Here, indeed, a friend
of mine helped me out,
Mo Yang who's running Consulting Humor.
He surveyed his audience,
which no surprise,
consists of lots of consultants.
And 1000s of people responded,
providing exact data, what
work firm they work for,
where they work, what
their base salary is,
what their expected bonuses
and many other information like this.
The data was collected
about three months ago.
So very recent and up to date.
But before we look at some numbers
let me provide some important remarks
for you to understand the
data in the best possible way.
First, all data is self-reported.
People filled out the survey.
Of course, this comes
with some limitations.
The data was not verified in any way.
Indeed, I do wanna give a shout out
to Mo Yang from Consulting Humor
who provided and collected all of this.
He has a huge Instagram account
with lots of consulting
comedy and consulting memes.
So check him out. I will
link his socials below.
He also started on YouTube, so help him.
Give him a subscribe as a
thank you for what he did here.
I do also wanna say
that I did only some very
limited data clean up
on the whole table of
1000s of respondents.
So I took out some obvious entry errors,
some clear outliers that
just were not realistic.
But surely there will be
some wrong entries left.
Of course, last but not least,
I personally cannot vouch
for any specific data
point that I'm sharing.
This is what was sent
to me in the big table
that Mo Yang collected here.
And it truly was also not verified
with any of the large consulting firms.
All of this said, I do have
a little goody for you,
And this is that I will provide
the full unedited data set
with 1000s of data points,
thee one that was also sent
to me for you as a download.
So find the download link
to this very big and extensive data set
in the video description.
So if you wanna know what people earn
for a very specific firm
you are interested in,
in a very specific region,
just download the big data set.
It is in a pivot table, friendly format.
So getting the insight that you need
is pretty straightforward.
Let's start with some basic facts
about the data set.
As you can see, there
are almost 4,000 people
who provided their information
on which consulting firm they work for.
The data set is dominated
by people working in MBB or in Big Four,
which I guess is no surprise,
but which is also the reason
I'm going to focus on
these firms in this video.
Whenever you talk about salaries,
it is important to
acknowledge that, of course,
there are very significant
regional differences.
Also when working for the same firm,
the salary that you will earn
if you work in the US, or
in India, or in Germany
will significantly change.
As you can see here the data
set is biased towards the US.
I will show you also
some slices of the data
with averages per country
to make these differences visible as well.
Before we jump into salary,
let's talk about working hours,
because this survey also
contained a question
on how long on average the people worked
in their consulting firm.
I visualized to see on
this little heat maps,
as you can see, besides MBB and Big 4,
I also included Accenture,
EY Parthenon and Strategy &.
I included these additional ones
because those who are companies
with more than 40 replies.
The data set contains data for
many other companies as well.
Just be sure to download it,
links are in video description
if you're interested
what the numbers are
for your specific firm.
So as you can see here for the MBB Firms,
so McKinsey, BCG and Bain,
they gravitate towards
60 to 69 hours on average
in terms of weekly working time.
McKinsey seems to be a
bit more on the upper end,
though the differences do
not seem too significant.
The Big 4 Firms do seem
to be quite similar.
So on average they seem to work a bit less
than the MBB Firms,
with the main range about
40 to 60 hours per week.
Accenture seems to be more
comparable to the Big 4
and then EY Parthenon and Strategy &,
more of the strategy consulting firms,
which makes, of course, sense.
From my personal experience
having actually worked at Accenture
for 1/2 a year as an
intern during university,
these numbers do seem very plausible.
And the same as through for MBB as well.
Obviously, please let
me know in the comments
whether you agree that this is
how your situation looks like
if you work for any of
these specific firms.
But let's now start with the salary data.
And let's start with the graduates.
So the data for those people
who just started their
career in consulting,
maybe are on the first or second year.
To read these tables correctly,
we always have the
average base salary first,
then you have the average bonus.
Here the people who are asked
what their expected bonus was
for the last full 12 months.
This means that if you're
really a high performer
who performs above average,
you will likely earn even more.
But if you perform below average,
your bonus might be smaller than this.
It is worthwhile to notice
though that in some countries,
in some firms you get also
additional compensation components.
This might for instance, be a company car,
which is very common in Germany.
It might also be for instance,
health insurance benefits,
or other insurance benefits.
Last but not least, on
the right you can see
how the total compensation
differs by US, India and Germany.
I chose these three countries
because from our audience analytics
I know that these are the
countries with the most viewers
here on the Firm Learning Channel.
So trust you can read
the numbers for yourself
if you were to pause the video
for some additional seconds
to process all the data.
When looking at the total
compensation of the MBB Firms.
You will see that these
are rather similar here
with the one outlier, Bain.
Plus you can see it's
only eight data points.
I looked into the raw data here,
the main reason is that there
are lots of people from India.
So if you look at the total
compensation by country,
you can see that then
for individual countries
the compensation is quite similar indeed.
Same is true for the Big 4.
So the compensation
values are rather similar,
with KPMG being a negative outlier.
Here once again, lots of people from Asia
replying here for KPMG.
If you look at the country split,
you can again see that the Big 4 salaries
are rather similar here
on the entry level.
By the way, when a number is
missing in the country split,
this just means that I only
had a handful of data points.
I felt this was then just
not valid to include.
So if you're interested in it,
again, you can download the
full unfiltered data set
via the link of the video description
to then look at this data as well.
Next, let's look at the salary
data for young professionals,
so people being in consulting
for about one to three years or so.
Again, you can read all
the numbers for yourself.
There is one thing though
that I would like to stress,
especially for the MBB Firms,
so McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
and this is their leave program.
So in almost all regions,
these MBB Firms will
offer you an opportunity
to after two or three years or so,
take a break from consulting
to pursue an MBA or a PhD
or a similar relevant project.
These contributions can easily be worth
one or two additional annual salaries.
So from everything I understand,
the value of these leave programs
is not properly factored
into the salary data here.
But I do know
that the attractiveness
of these leave programs
differed significantly
also within the MBB Firms,
which was also one of the reasons
when then I decided to join the firm,
which you know I joined.
So make sure to research properly
what this leave program looks like.
And you also be aware that
even within the same firm,
depending on the region
these programs can look quite differently.
Last but not least,
the salaries for more
seasoned consultants,
so for the project leads.
You will typically reach this level
after three to five years or so
depending on how fast you get promoted
and on what level exactly you started.
In this level the salary gap
of working at McKinsey
or BCG compared to Bain,
no doubt slowly start to seem to open up.
Whereas on the Big 4 end,
it does seem to still be quite homogenous.
Overall, when looking
at the regional trends,
we can see that the US
salaries are highest.
But these, of course,
do also come with likely
the highest living costs
if you're based in coastal cities
on the East Coast or the West Coast.
Then you have the situation in Germany.
Probably comparing Germany to
some other countries in the U,
Germany likely is on the
upper end of the salaries
that you will get.
So if you work, for
instance, in Spain or Italy,
your salaries are likely going
to be a little bit smaller.
Again, you can look at this
yourself in the full data set.
And then, of course, salaries in India
and also some other Asian countries
will be significantly lower.
So I do hope you found this insightful,
and I would love to hear
from you and the comments.
Based on your experience,
are these numbers accurate?
If you took any value
out of this video at all,
just hit the like button
for the YouTube algorithm
and subscribe to this channel
to stay up to date on all the content.
Also, a big shout out to Consulting Humor
for putting all of this together.
I trust the data set is
extremely insightful.
If you wanna download the full thing,
link to it in the video description.
A big thank you to all the
members supporting this channel.
My name is Heinrich from Firm Learning.
I release new videos
every single Saturday.
So, see you soon again next
week. Until then, bye bye.